well it's hard to find in this country a
bigger supporter of
lockdowns than the emmy award-winning
governor of new york andrew cuomo
in april to name one among a thousand
examples governor cuomo mocked anyone
who quest
anyone who questioned lockdowns as
science deniers what's worse than
death cuomo asked in other words stay in
your tiny
apartment watch netflix and
rot don't see your friends or family
don't go to school don't go to work not
that your job exists anymore
stay alone by the way we've got some
weed for you so you won't remember it
in order to protect life we need to
destroy lives that was andrew cuomo's
philosophy
all year long a bar or restaurant
that is violating these rules can lose
their liquor license if you are
non-essential worker
you shouldn't be leaving your home i
want local governments
to enforce the social distancing
rules so we're going to increase the
potential maximum
fine from 500 to 1 000
when i issued the stay-at-home order it
wasn't
it would be nice if you did
it is a mandate you should be happy
because if we don't change the
trajectory we're going to go to shut
down and then your business is going to
close
okay just to make sure we have it clear
rapists
you're fine head down to the subway
good luck anyone who violates andrew
cuomo's
arbitrary lockdown orders will face the
full power of the state he said that for
months but then this week in a plot
twist that nobody saw coming in the
enormous scripted drama that is american
politics andrew cuomo changed on a dime
to the other direction he did win an
emmy after all
here's what andrew cuomo wrote in a
tweet today yes we follow him quote
we simply cannot stay closed until the
vaccine hits critical mass
the cost is too high we'll have nothing
left to open
we must reopen the economy but we must
do it smartly and safely
well if that sounds strangely familiar
it may be because
two months ago the much reviled and
often criticized governor of the state
of florida the free state of florida ron
desantis
said exactly the same thing but ron
desantis is a republican presiding over
one of the few free states left in the
country so cnn and twitter
instantly told us that was irresponsible
and dangerous
censor him immediately anything to
prevent
you from realizing how little they know
and how badly new york is doing
compared to the rest of the country but
now we do know